hey it's Kennedy for reason American
Atheists have launched a billboard
campaign trying to convert the hearts
and minds of Hasidic Jews and Muslims
and ethnically diverse Williamsburg
Brooklyn trying to make the atheists
will at work find out hey man have you
seen the billboards the Atheist
billboard hey have you uh have you seen
the billboards they put up in your
neighborhood it says
have you seen the the billboard that the
atheists put up no buy a dump it says
you know it's a myth you have a choice
they're there they're targeting atheists
in your community they want to see if
they're atheists out there and they want
to convert them to atheist is that
offensive okay
I don't think he's coming back so I'm
here with Dave Silverman he's the
president of American Atheists trying to
convert some of the Hasidic and Muslim
folks here in Williamsburg Brooklyn
we're not trying to convert anybody what
that will do is it will raise awareness
to the atheists in the Hasidic
communities that the movement exists
that we know they're here isn't calling
someone's religion a myth isn't it like
it is it's still a myth and it's still
alive you know it is but to them it's
it's completely sacred shouldn't you
have some respect for other people's
believe we have respect for people we do
not have to have respect for beliefs if
you believe in Santa Claus you have the
risk you have the right tourism to do
that
and we respect your right to believe in
Santa Claus but we're not gonna sit here
and tell you to your face yeah that's a
valid thing to believe it's not we've
gotten a dozen 12 12 well emails from
closeted Hasidic Jews before the
billboards went up all right well Dave
thanks so much thank you